[music]
principles of success fascinating
half-hour story
episode 8 episode 1 an
invitation to the journey before I
start let me just assure you that
I don't know much about what exactly I need to know
all the success I have achieved in life
is due, and rather, to the fact that I know how
to cope with my ignorance than to
use  because I know teaching and
mentoring is pretty
presumptuous,
but I do it because I believe that the
principles that have helped me achieve
success can help others achieve
their goals,
now I have entered a time in my life when
it is much more important for me to pass on my
experience of success to others than  to achieve
even greater success for yourself is up to
you how you choose
to deal with these principles
it is important to think for yourself because
only you can develop
your own principles based on your
own values
and from this follows my first and most
important principle that in general you
should be on your own  deliberation  typing what
exactly to the song and now let's start
at the beginning i found that i need a
principle a principle and these are the rules of a
rational approach to any action
and phenomenon repeated over and over again
similar situations there are principles of everything from
skiing to raising children
cooking and so on I
'm going to share  some of my
most important and all-encompassing life
principles that govern our approach to
everything we do but I didn't get lost in the beginning
I developed them throughout my
life mostly from
mistakes made and reflection days my life
principles are simple but they are not exhaustive
to this day I  I try my
best to make the best decision I still make
mistakes and constantly extract
new principles from this and this is reality first
I had to free
myself from the conventions that surrounded me and that
meant thinking for yourself if you
do not want
others to control your life you should
decide
what to do yourself  for this
you  it will take courage at first I didn’t
know it and learned it only on the journey itself
looking back at the life
path I have traveled I now see that time is like a
river carrying us to clashes with
reality requiring us to make a
decision it is not in our power to stop the
movement along this river and these  collisions are
inevitable we can only prepare for
them as much as
possible during your lifetime you will have to
make millions of decisions the quality of
your decisions depends on the quality of your
life during my lifetime the most valuable
thing I learned was the result of mistakes
that I reflected on to
formulate principles that allow not to
repeat  the same mistakes thanks to this
principle i am an ordinary child and a
middle-class family from long island reached
significant by conventional standards
narrow thanks to them i have an interesting
meaningful job and the same
relationships with others i value it even
more than the usual mixture people often
ask how i do it  succeeded I assure you
not at all because of my uniqueness as a
person, it is the result of a unique
approach to life that I believe
each of you can adopt,
it begins with the acceptance and
understanding of reality and relationship
with it in the second episode, I will explain what
this means the most important of your  decisions
it is your choice and your life books as
far as I am concerned I wanted my life to
be beautiful I was afraid of the boredom of
mediocrity more than of failures
because in the beginning I had no money
and only needed a roof over my head and
food in my journey I could try
different solutions so  that since childhood I have been
chasing this and falling for this I got up and
ran again and fell again and with each
fall I learned something I became
smarter I fell less often I
repeat it again and again I learned to
love this process even falling
thanks to him I was faced with reality
and  learned to cope with and this
inspired another one of my
founding principles the
truth is necessary and again good
results under and  truth I mean
only how the world works
I believe that the law of reality given to us by
nature they are not created by people but we
can use them to promote
our own development and to
achieve our goals
thanks to this conclusion I became a hyper-
realist, that is, I realized that a deep
understanding of this given to us  reality and
acceptance of cooperation with it they with the
imaginary world of our dreams
rewards a person a hundredfold when I
declare that I am a hyper realist of the environment
sometimes they think that the meaning of this is that
dreams do not come true it is completely
wrong without a dream life becomes an
everyday bustle as far as I am concerned
hyperrealism is the best way  choose
your goals and then achieve their high
goals
plus acceptance and comprehension of reality
plus not a dozen determination will give you a
successful life I believe that this formula is
true for everyone but what constitutes a
successful life
each of us must decide for ourselves
what success is I still want  whether you
become the master  the universe to live under a
palm tree or anything else,
this does not concern me, each of us
sets a goal and based on
our own value and chooses the
best way to achieve them, but we all
need an approach to making effective
decisions, especially when we are faced with
difficulties, mistakes, weaknesses that
arise  on our way, in order to reach the
goal, we must take for granted all the
realities of our environment, especially harsh
realities, extremely undesirable
at the beginning, even the realization of these harsh
realities turned out to be very sick for me,
but gradually I came to the conclusion that this
pain was purely psychological and that a
different view of what was happening  radically
changes how I perceive it I began to
perceive difficulties as puzzles
that will reward me when solved they
help to cope with difficulties and at the
same time become a source of principles for
solving similar problems in the future I have
learned to perceive pain as a
hint that I have an excellent opportunity to
learn
something from this  P  examined the conclusion pain plus
reflection equals progress as an invaluable
help in this form and became
meditation I found that calm
acceptance of realities and their understanding
reward me
satisfaction and the pain goes away each of
us is endowed with a unique ability
to think logically reflect on ourselves and
our circumstances and guide
our own development  a
simple 5 step process helps to accomplish this in the
third episode we learn how to
apply it
we discussed the importance of careful
self-analysis after painful sensations by
resorting to it I usually found
principles to avoid similar
mistakes in the future thanks to this I realized
that we are only five steps away from success
stages step 1 know your goals and
strive to achieve them
your aspirations depend on your essence
therefore you need to really understand
yourself and know what you want to
achieve in life second step identify the
difficulties and obstacles that stand in the way
of achieving your goals
they are like  the rule of the disease if you do not
cope with them and some can
ruin you but in order to develop you
should identify these difficulties and
obstacles and not put up with them
step 3 is to understand the nature of these
difficulties and get to their essence but you
should not rush into a decision
take a closer look and think about how to distinguish
symptoms
of illness step 4 develop a plan to
eliminate obstacles here you
determine what needs to be done to
get around them and finally step 5 to implement your
plan pushing yourself to what it
takes to move towards your goal in
essence a successful life is to
constantly repeat these five steps
this is your  personal evolution and this
process is happening everywhere it's just a
law of nature
think about any subject of any
organization or your friends and you
will see that this applies to all of them
evolution is just a process or
adaptation or perish
in essence evolution is like the
5 stage process I have already mentioned, making your way
through these often illnesses  under given
circumstances you naturally
climb new and new heights of
success I found that despite my
achievements these circumstances never
got easier because with the development of
abilities I tried to overcome more and
more difficult
obstacles each of us has his own strengths and
weaknesses and therefore the successful passage of
all  five stages beyond the power of most,
only the recognition of this reality will allow
you not to waste energy and as the
height of the obstacles, the fall also
becomes more and more diseases,
we all had to face
terrible life circumstances, they can
destroy us or, depending on
how we cope with numbness  give
us a new new family
something similar happened to me in 1982
the
fourth episode i will tell you what
happened and what lessons i learned from it
we move forward until we
face setbacks we cope with
them and move on or be
thrown back depends on our
desire  accept failure as an
objective phenomenon and make the right
decision to get back on track
and move on again in 1982,
something terrible happened to me when I
staked everything I had in
anticipation of a depression that would not
give way
between 1979 and 1980 turned out to be
extremely  turbulent for the world economy for the
markets and for me, and therefore I believed
that the US economy is tied to it by the
world economy
moving disaster
this view was very controversial I wanted to
hit the big jackpot openly took a
serious risk and I was wrong and just
as seriously after a while the
stock market  began to rise sharply this
growth continued for the next 18 years
followed by the longest period of
growth of the US economy in history my mistake
was like hitting a baseball bat on the
head I had to cover the
losses incurred as a result of which my
bridge company was left with one employee
I myself was so broke  that I
had to borrow 4 thousand from my father  and dollars
to pay the bills,
but even more difficult was the dismissal of
employees who were so door to
me, I even wondered if I should
give up the dream of working for myself and
lead a carefree life as a self-employed person,
go to chats in the office daily neckties,
although I knew that for me less  the risk
means a mediocre life to
be wrong and so
openly wrong it was painful and
humiliating to this day I am still
shocked and ashamed how
arrogant my reckless
confidence in completely wrong
judgments was, although in general I turned out to be right
much more often than wrong a single
wrong bet destroyed the fruits  all the best
this got me thinking seriously about the
relationship between risk and
reward and how to manage it but I
couldn't figure out how to get the
reward I wanted without taking unacceptable risk
this happens to everyone
it happens to you and you end up
losing something or someone without something
life will become either life or b  you will
suffer from a terrible illness or injury,
or your career will collapse in an instant
, thoughts will immediately come that life is
over and nothing else shines, but
this will pass, I assure you there is always a way out,
you most likely haven’t
seen it yet, you just need to
think carefully about how it is  find you
have to accept the reality in which you find
yourself in episode 5 i will show how this conclusion
led me to ask how
reality works and how best to
deal with it sometimes what is happening
around us is difficult to understand life often
seems to us so difficult and
confusing that we immediately embrace everything with an
understanding above our own  the
all-consuming pain I experienced
made me think deeply about my
circumstances it also made me
think about the world around me as
it leaves us in search of truth
so I thought a lot about how everything
works and it helped me to see myself
and my circumstances in a more  in a broader
context,
I realized that with pain  in our explosion, all the
laws of the force of the universe were created and
launched
in an interaction like a perpetual
motion machine in which all small and large
parts merge into a single mechanism that
works by some then
falling apart they merge into a
new mechanism
that continues for all eternity I saw
that everything around
is a mechanism the structure of evolution  galaxies the
formation of our solar system the
formation of the geography and ecosystems of the
earth our economy and market and each
of us all and mechanisms consisting of a
variety of smaller mechanisms
our circulatory system our nervous
system that produce our thoughts
our dreams and our emotions and all other
fruits of our format
evolving with  over time, all these
diverse mechanisms create the realities
that we face daily and I
realized that I am just a tiny particle
in 1 nanosecond deciding what follows
although such a view may seem
very philosophical I discovered its
practicality it showed me how best to
sleep  e.g.
I have noticed that most events
happen again and will be able to but each time a
little differently some that follow an
obvious short-term cycle that is
easy to recognize and therefore we know how
to deal with them e.g. 24-hour
day some that happen so
rarely that I happen to  encounter
them in a lifetime but when it does
happen we are shocked e.g. a rare
loss storm that happens once a century
some we know but encounter
for the first time e.g. the birth of the first child
most people mistakenly consider these
situations to be unique and behave in them
without due regard for the future  or
principles that help to cope with it, I
guessed that these events should be
taken not as one-time events, but as just
another of many,
and considered as a biologist studies
animals, first to establish its
belonging to a certain species
and then relies on certain
principles for considering it in essence
yes  As soon as I managed to understand that these
events happen again and again almost the
same way, I was able to more clearly see the
cause-and-effect relationships that
determine their behavior, and this allowed
me to develop more adequate principles
that can be formed
both verbally and in the form of an algorithm, and I realized that
most people expect that the future
will be a slightly modified version of the
present, but it is usually very
different from it, this is due to the fact that
people think under the influence of recent
history and ignore events that have not
happened for a long
time, perhaps not even during their
lives, but these events will happen again from
this position, I became  the reason for
my misguided expectation of a new great
depression was clearly hidden in historical
patterns
and I could use my new
knowledge of these pattern patterns
to make better decisions in the
future and when I thought about the obstacles I
faced i.e. risk
reward I realized that risk and
the rewards go down and I realized that
the higher the aspiration in life, the greater the
risk that comes with it and that knowing
how to properly balance the risks of the
reward is a sine qua non
for achieving these aspirations.
successfully traversing the
dangerous jungle it's essentially a
choice everyone faces for me the choice
was clear
but that doesn't mean the path
will be smoother I still had to
face two major
hurdles we all
face in episode six i'll talk about
some of their invaluable tricks
to enable  to overcome them, I cannot
predict which path in life seems
better than others for each of you, since
I do not know how important significant goals are for you,
given the sacrifice and
torment that accompanies the process of
achieving these goals,
it takes courage to decide on this, which I
said earlier and  each of us should
feel it in ourselves after my big
mistakes anticipation of depression was at a
crossroads as happens to everyone if
I decided to choose a regular risk-free
job
my life would be completely different
but as long as I could pay for housing and two
children's education the
only choice for  I took the risk of
trekking through the jungle in pursuit of another
better life possible but I fatally
misled a bet on depression gave
me a healthy fear of being wrong
in other words she gave me deep
humility and she seemed
exactly what
I needed at the same time she didn't
stop me  energetically striving for
chewing to succeed on this
path I needed to broaden my
horizons
but it was we who interfered with the two biggest
obstacles faced by
our entire ego and our blindness so
-called blind spots perception these
obstacles are inseparable from the work of our
brain
first of all consider this obstacle
mentioning  I mean it  and the
human brain that prevent you from objectively
recognizing your weaknesses in order to
understand how to deal with them
the deepest needs and fears are
embedded in the brain regions that control
our emotions and cannot be perceived at
a higher level levels of consciousness, and
since our need to be right
can dominate over the need to
find out what is true  we tend to
trust our own opinions
without checking them against
reality, and we especially don’t like to
sort out our mistakes and shortcomings,
we instinctively tend to react to
such an analysis as aggression, while we
begin to get angry, although it’s more logical to be
open to it, especially from
others,
as a result, we accept  not an adequate
solution, we study less and narrow our
capabilities; the second obstacle is
blindness or blind spots.
It is a natural fact that people cannot
appreciate what they do not see,
just as we all have different
ranges of hearing height and
perception of colors, but with different ranges
in order to see and understand things,
for example, some people
perceive the picture of reality better in general
and others perfectly  distinguish the lower
detail some who think straight
others panoramic some creative
natures but you can’t rely on them and
others reliable but not endowed with
creative abilities and so on
because the firmware of our brain is
different we all perceive the
world around us differently do about what we
have a natural inclination  we do not
take into account our weaknesses and fail,
either we follow this inclination and
either we change Aristotle defined
tragedy as the terrible consequences of a fatal
mistake of a person and if it were corrected at the
time, the consequences would be
excellent in my opinion these two
obstacles are the main obstacles
correct  my fear of
being wrong gave me
an absolute openness of mind that
I lack and it changed everything
taking risks sometimes losing
was unacceptable for me
no one else could achieve
outstanding results without risk I
needed an approach that would give me
exceptional benefits  insensitive
negative consequences when it was
discovered it turned out to be my
lifesaver to get
it I had to give up the joy of being
right
and replace it with the joy of knowing that the
truth this need prompted me
to look for the most deeply thinking people
who would not agree myself I did not
care about their conclusions I  I just wanted to
see the eyes surrounding her and so that they
could see those around me with my eyes
so that together we could figure out
that the truth, in other words, I needed from them
most of all, was thought out, I do not
agree with the
transition from the limitations of my own
view of others to the vision of the
environment  the eyes of these thinking people
were like a transition from a black and white
movie to a color
world filled with light that's when I realized
that the best help in the jungle of life is
thinking insightful people whose view of
the environment is different from us you will
remember the appetite about us the process
described by me earlier
as me  already said due to differences in our
firmware, not everyone manages to successfully
complete all five of these, but it is not at all
necessary to do all this alone,
you can get help from others who,
unlike you, are successful in something, that is,
whose firmware allows them to
perceive that  what is not available
for you to do this, you just need to get rid of the
habit of looking for the right answer
alone and instead of being afraid of being
wrong,
becoming open to the views and opinions of
others
thanks to this you will be able to notice the
risks and opportunities that you have
missed acting on your own,
I found that this is a decisive
openness and  a critical attitude to the
thinking of other people
will not significantly increase  the
likelihood of making the best decisions
and this allowed me to achieve more but
also to face more serious
difficulties earlier I would have strived to do
what I thought was best
but now I strove with all my might to find the
most profound and original
thinkers there is nothing better than
doing things together  with outstanding
people
consistently frank and completely
open in dealing with others,
this approach has led me to create a
company on a unique basis of a
kind of idea meritocracy
working in a unique way that
leads to incomparable success in
idea meritocracy everyone's contribution is the
best that he can give everyone
thinks about the issue on their own then
we sort it out  in our disagreements, in
order to choose the best option,
however, not all opinions are equally valuable, and in
order to make the best decisions, we
had to learn to distinguish between good
flea diets, in other words, we need to
weigh the plausibility of the fruits of
mental activity,
but that's about  the bottom story that I
will explain in the principles of work before us is
always a lot of great
opportunities accompanied by dangerous
risks that you cannot see if we were
aware of these risks without
distorting our mountains and our
blindness,
we could overcome them more
effectively if you manage to acquire this
ability
you can drastically improve
yours in the eighth episode I complete our
journey and now you are ready
to go on your own so
far I have told how I learned to
face my own real
difficulties, mistakes and weaknesses
and how I surrounded myself with people who are capable
of more than me and  this turned out to be the
most effective method for making
great decisions this method is unusual
but it is because of them that I succeeded
and it allowed me to meet
other extremely successful people and
understand their way of thinking I found
that the journey of each of them is similar to
mine perhaps you  you don't know it but
they are all in a struggle all the time and they all have
weaknesses
that they overcome working with
people who replace risks opportunities
that they did not notice over time I
realized that due to human nature the
most strengths of most people are
accompanied by their most
significant shortcomings and  that the
relentless striving for the top is
inevitably accompanied by a painful
fall it is just an integral
part of the process
such a fall is a test they
sort people some
think deeply about the reasons for their failures and
learn from them and continue
to move towards their goals
and others decide that this game is not for them
and  leave the site I realized that success
is not a matter of achieving one’s goals I didn’t
find that each new larger
success leaves a feeling of satisfaction less and less
what we strive for is just the lure the
desire for it makes us
develop and it is this struggle for
personal development that is the reward for
me b  I didn't feel like wading
through the jungle anymore, instead I
strove to overcome more and more
difficulties, surrounded by outstanding
personalities, acting together on our
common journey, in the end, the success of
this journey and the well-being of those
accompanying me on it became
more important to me than my own success, I also began
to pay more attention  on others and
contribute to their transformation into successful
people even when I am no longer around
I understand that if I do not do this I
will fail now I am doing my
best to avoid it
we are all constantly fighting for something
until we decide or ourselves to get rid of
this  struggle, or until we die and become
part of a common evolutionary history, this is
how all mechanisms work, they are destroyed and reappear
when the mechanism breaks down, its details
return to the outside world to
become part of new mechanisms that
also sanitizes currencies during sometimes this
upsets us, since we are very
attached to  our mechanisms
but if you look at it abstractly, the
beauty of the functioning of the
mechanism of evolution in time is amazing now you
have to decide how to develop
further
forget about where the principles I described come from
just evaluate whether they are useful to you and
develop them according to your
needs as in all life decisions
only from  it depends on you what you do with them
my only hope is that you
will have the courage to fight and seek
find and not give up thank you and all the best
[music]